hey welcome back to New Rockstars it's
me Mt and with Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 introducing yet another child hero
to the MCU who could Marvel be setting
up the next generation of Avengers
before our very eyes I mean we've gotten
Iron Man's daughter Morgan Stark Hulk's
son scar Hawkeye's son Nathaniel Thor's
adoptive daughter love to tallah Son
Tucson and the parental Guardians of the
Galaxy's phyla introduced in such quick
succession could these next Avengers of
Tomorrow team up with the Avengers of
today by the end of the Multiverse Saga
with Avengers Kang Dynasty and Secret
Wars well let's speculate speculation
because I believe some insane time
travel shenaniganery is about to go down
but like always do not forget to hit up
nerd riot.shop today so you can pick up
a new nerd shirt for you or somebody
that you love we got some cool Guardians
three shirts but they're only going to
be around for a little bit so head on
over to nerdwide.job today we need new
Heroes one suited for the Times we're in
and Sam Wilson is right of course in
Marvel Studios agrees with us now being
in the Multiverse Saga Marvel Studios
has also been setting the scenes for a
future much farther ahead than we
realized not just with their slowly
introducing the Young Avengers cast of
characters like Kate Bishop America
Chavez Eli Bradley and Billy and Tommy
maximoff or newer Avengers to be alike
chihok seongchi ironheart and Miss
Marvel but beyond that into a much
farther future through the introduction
of the children of the Avengers who will
eventually end up being a symbolic
replacement for the infinity Saga
Avengers team the mcu's adaptation of a
team from the comics known as the next
Avengers your younger Young Avengers but
from the future like Marty McFly and it
appears that the MCU adaptation of the
next Avengers might just include Morgan
Stark as a new Iron woman or rescue
Nathaniel Barton named after Natasha
Romanov as the next Hawkeye t'challa
Junior as the future black panther scar
as the next Hulk love as Thor's Divine
adopt of daughter Moondragon and the
adoptive daughter of the Guardians phyla
as the cosmic Powerhouse Quasar and the
Future Love of moondragon's life but
luckily the beauty of the Multiverse
Saga is that us impatient nerds don't
have to wait years for all these little
kids to age up naturally we don't have
to do that we have the technology phase
four and five MCU projects like Loki
Multiverse Madness what if and
quantumania have been teasing us of
multiple universes in timelines
converging together through the Marvel
Multiverse potentially leading us into
an all-out catastrophe of incursions in
the next Avengers movies Kane Dynasty
and Secret Wars and ever since Sylvie
broke the entire multiversal structure
arranged by he who remains and the TVA
in the Loki finale any person in the
Multiverse from any point in time could
potentially accidentally make their way
to MCU 616 including the children of the
OG Avengers who will end up forming
their own Avengers team in the far
future which is something that actually
happens in a super crazy Kang storyline
from the comics nipple babies MRI
because you see and a Brian Michael
Bennis Avengers run from 2010 King the
Conqueror does some Tick-Tock cuckoo
clock Malarkey and managed to break the
whole dang Multiverse as Kang loves to
do sometimes causing random people
elements in Wars from different
timelines to converge in the modern New
York City like apocalypse and His Four
Horsemen popped up from the past devil
dinosaur and invading alien Army from
the future I mean Galactus even showed
up like chick got Bananas in Pajamas man
so in order to fix Kang's mistake a
couple of modern day Avengers journey
across time and team up with a future
version of The Avengers team called the
index Avengers that was made up of some
of the Avengers children you know like
Steve Rogers and Natasha romanov's son
James Rogers named after Bucky t'challa
and the mutant storm son Azari t'challa
Francis Barton the son of Hawkeye and
Mockingbird Hank Pym Jr the son of Hank
Pym and Janet Van Dyne and torum the
daughter of Thor and Lady sip long story
shorts together with the modern day
Avengers they figure out a way to stop
Kang from breaking the Multiverse and
eventually even end up executing a Kang
variant in an absolutely brutal fashion
and good riddance I say like if you read
that run that Kang was an but
anyways it's looking like the MCU might
be setting up a similar next Avengers
team with the children of Tony Stark the
war Hawkeye Hulk t'challa and the
Guardians of the Galaxy and even
possibly the child of one Steven Rogers
a deleted scene from Avengers end game
of Tony Starks saying goodbye to a
grown-up Morgan Stark played by
Catherine Langford did reveal that
Marvel Studios has been thinking of
setting the seeds for the coming of an
aged up Morgan Stark as early as
Infinity war and endgame and since we do
also learn that dreams are a window to
the Multiverse in Multiverse of Madness
Tony start telling pepper that he
dreamed of Morgan in Infinity War might
just hint at the many Morgans of the
Multiverse that will soon factor into
Kane's narrative via the MCU next
Avengers and look guys Father's Day is
coming up fast and if you want to get
your father a gift that he'll use every
day you should check out ridge ridge has
reinvented the wallet and it's a massive
improvement over the bulky dad wallets
of yesteryear the ridge wallet is slim
but expands to hold up to 12 cards plus
Cash Bridge wallets come in over 30
colors and styles including carbon fiber
burnt titanium forged Ember and burnt
Damascus plus these wallets are designed
with the 21st century in mind each
wallet is built with RFID blocking
materials that protects your info from
digital pickpockets and has an optional
air tag attachment so you'll never lose
your wallet again find the best Father's
Day gift by going to ridge.com new
rockstars right now and you can save up
to 40 through June 15th that is
ridge.com new rockstars we thank Rich
for sponsoring this video and for
protecting my money but moving on
Hawkeye Sun Nathaniel Barton to me is
the most likely to become the next
Hawkeye not just because this child was
named after Natasha which makes him a
more powerful and Superior child than
most but also because Nathaniel was the
only one of Hawkeye's children worn
after Clint spent a ton of time around
blue Tesseract radiation possibly
mutating Hawkeye's genetics to produce a
mutant Sun you know much like the blue
energy of the telecon plant affected
Neymar's mother so I feel like we could
see an older Nathaniel Barton mutant
Hawkeye introduced in preparation for
the mutant era of the MCU Professor
Xavier himself got his mutant Powers
through his parents being exposed to
radiation in a similar way chiho
introduced Hulk's son's scar fresh from
sakar with a hairline that sure is far
went back to the future while
definitely not as young as the other
kids on the next Avengers since hulks
have a super long lifespan scar would
fit very well with the next Avengers
team when they come of age to kick butt
t'challa and nakia's Son Tucson is a
shoe-in for the team as t'challa's son
Azari in the comics was also on the next
Avengers team much like I've brought up
in a previous video revealing the secret
Name of Love Before love and thunder
there are strong signals from Taiko
watiti that Uncle Thor's adoptive
daughter niece figure love will become
the future Moon Dragon one of the most
powerful Cosmic Heroes on the map in the
Marvel Universe mostly because her
father or the god butcher is strongly
connected to dragons of Darkness
urging from moons and Gore's daughter
love is obsessed with Dragons herself
even drawing a dragon on a rock on her
home planet and also playing with a
paper dragon as Thor gets her ready for
the day and since it has been suddenly
hinted that love can lift mjolnir since
she was able to make a tiny bed from
mjolnir she could very well end up
inheriting mjolnir in the future to help
Channel her crazy powers and much like
in the comics the super-powered phyla of
the Guardians of the Galaxy will very
likely become the superhero Quasar the
keeper of eon's quantum bands with the
cosmic entity Eon being introduced in
4-4 as one of those statues in that
weird Cosmic hallway I have been telling
everybody on my twitter.com to expect
phyla to come to the MCU soon and here
she is like I truly believe that they
made phyla a child in the MCU at this
point in preparation for time travel
Shenanigans to age both her and
Moondragon up so the tale of moon dragon
and quasar's historic romance can be
told as they save the world together but
while those six members are who I
believe will be on the mcu's next
Avengers team we cannot forget one of
the mcu's biggest Revelations and recent
memories Captain America Mr Rogers has
been around the neighborhood of pound
town so there could be a little Rogers
out there that we don't know about yet
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
maths retainment on Twitter if you guys
want to see me tweet some weird and
really fun theories but most importantly
you can follow new Roxas wherever we are
on social medias love you guys so much
and I'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
foreign